FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you
everyone for being here.
Welcome today.
In 1986, Massimo Bottura
bought a roadside trattoria.
He had no culinary
training and no experience.
Despite this, the
restaurant, which
served traditional Emilian
dishes, was a great success.
In 1993, Alain Ducasse
visited the trattoria
and invited Massimo to cook at
Hotel de Paris in Monte Carlo.
After this life-changing
experience--
imagine going from a trattoria
to a three Michelin star
restaurant-- he opened
a new restaurant,
Osteria Francescana, in
Modena's Historic Center.
He was no longer cooking
traditional recipes,
but provocative
Italian renditions,
which were received with
skepticism and doubt.
In fact, it took 10 years from
receiving his first Michelin
star in 2001 to receiving his
third star, Michelin's highest
rating, in 2012.
Why?
Because in Italy, the idea
of tradition and evolution
is not easy for
anyone to accept.
Today, the restaurant is
rated the best in Italy.
And for the second
consecutive year,
Osteria Francescana ranked
third in San Pellegrino's list
of the world's 50
best restaurants.
Massimo's food blends
tradition with innovation,
managing to capture the essence
of classic Italian dishes
via modern expressions.
One of the ways he
achieves this is
by marrying his passion
for food with his love
of contemporary art.
He is also known for
the playful names
he gives his dishes,
like a signature dish,
Oops, I Dropped the Lemon Tart.
Earlier this week,
on Jimmy Kimmel,
he made and fed Jimmy his iconic
recipe, Memory of a Mortadella
Sandwich.
We have a three-minute
video to show you now
of Massimo in his
restaurant in Modena, Italy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm born and I grew up in the
land of fast car and slow food.
I learned, since I was a
kid, to think very quick.
As the Roman they were
saying, think quick.
Do it very quick, but slowly.
That means have a very quick
thought, but do it slowly.
Because you need a lot
of time to do something.
They interpret
what I'm thinking,
and they know what I'm thinking.
So here we go.
Oops, We Dropped the Lemon Tart.
Food, for Italians, is like
the soccer team, or the Pope,
or the food-- in order.
Soccer team first, Pope
second, tradition third.
I remember all these
gastronomic trips
I took with my older
brothers because my mom was
pushing me-- go, go, go.
Don't just play soccer.
Because I was playing
soccer every day.
I think of those
kinds of experiences--
they were a totally
important part of my life.
Because going on Mont
Saint-Michel or [? Angelo ?]
[? Gallo ?] visiting
the wine cellar.
Drive to Nice, eat
oyster, get drunk,
going back for the night.
And say Mom, but Massimo,
where have you been?
Uh, studying.
[ITALIAN]
How can I forget about
the taste of lasagna?
It's impossible.
Or the piece of
Parmesan, or a drop
of 50 years old
balsamic vinegar.
That's magic.
So what we have to do is
just that see everything
from the distance, see what's
wrong and what's right,
and bring just the best
part into the future.
The book is going to be about
my passion, the evolution
of my ideas-- food, a
dose of art, and music.
Maybe, as I always
said, through passion,
I'm going to transfer emotions.
Maybe the book, at the end,
is going to be about emotion.
I don't know.
I hope so.
Get deep into things is one
of the most important things.
I hope people that
are going to read--
how is the structure
of creativity,
and they're going to be
inspired by this structure.
Express yourself.
That's the point.
Feel free.
Be brave.
I always say to
the young chef, be
focused on what is your dream.
You can realize that.
That's the scary part. [LAUGH]
[END PLAYBACK]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Please join me
in welcoming Massimo Bottura.
[APPLAUSE]
MASSIMO BOTTURA: Hi everyone.
I'm Massimo Bottura.
I'm an Italian chef.
And I grew up in
Modena-- Modena,
in the middle of Emilia-Romagna,
in the center of Italy.
So it is where the Ferrari
car, the Maserati, Lamborghini,
Ducati, are made, but
also Parmigiano-Reggiano,
balsamic vinegar.
So it's like is
the land of-- as I
said-- slow food and fast car.
I grew up in a very large family
in which my older brothers,
they were chasing me all the
time, because I was the younger
one.
And my safety place
was the kitchen,
where my grandmother
was rolling pasta.
And I could sneak
under the table,
and she was defending
me with the mattarello,
rolling the pasta,
saying, get out of here.
Just because he's the
younger one-- get out!
So in the meantime, I was
stealing the tortellini
from up.
And for me, that's
why tortellini
are the most important and the
most iconic dish of my life,
and especially when
they are rolled.
Because you can feel exactly
the flavor of the filling.
My father was planning
for me to be a lawyer.
Can you imagine?
And so after two
years of my studies,
I dropped everything--
because my passion
were food, art, and music.
And out of the
blue, we found out
that there was a small
trattoria outside of Modena
called Trattoria del Campazzo.
I didn't even know
where it was--
a small village
with three houses
and a small restaurant
in the middle.
My brother took
me there and said,
this is the perfect
place for you.
It's the place where
you can express yourself
through the food,
through your passion.
Said to Paolo, what do you
think is-- are you sure?
He said, yes.
This is the perfect place.
One week later, I was there,
because the food world
chose me.
It's not that I chose that.
That was the perfect timing.
And in that moment,
I realized I had
to put all myself
into this world,
because I have to show
everyone it was so right,
the choice I made.
And the simplest interest
for food, step by step,
became a passion.
And through the
passion, I realized
you can transfer emotions.
That what I think food is, and
how I interpret the food-- just
transfer emotions.
I cooked in Trattoria del
Campazzo for seven years.
Since once a great chef
from France, Alain Ducasse,
came and met me.
He invited me to work at Hotel
de Paris, in Monte Carlo.
So I went there.
I left everything.
I went there and I started
learning, working like 16 hours
a day-- so to learn
everything, from chocolate
to bread, baking, everything.
And since they called
me, Trattoria de Campazzo
and the [? club-- ?]
Massimo, we need you.
You have to come back.
So I left.
I have to go back
to my real life.
That was a dream, a bubble.
And in the moment I was
living in Monte Carlo,
I met Mr. Ducasse in
the hall of the hotel.
And he was asking me, you
know, so, Massimo, did you do?
Did you have a good experience?
You know, the classic question.
I said, fantastic.
Look at this.
I have the whole notebook full
of everything, also recipes
that I've stolen from there.
So he looked at
me very carefully.
He grabbed the notebook,
and he crash in the middle,
and he throw in the
garbage, saying,
you are ready to stand
up with your feet.
Just walk.
I was like, in shock.
I was like, all these months,
all these hours-- you know,
the sweating and the experience,
everything in the garbage.
But that was the most
important experience
of my life, the moment
that changed my life.
Because in that moment,
in that exact moment,
I felt I had to do and
I had to express myself
through what I've learned
in all of these months.
One year later, we opened
Osteria Francescana.
But everything changed
because of the experience
in New York and Monte Carlo.
So those recipes-- they were
so successful in Campazzo,
in the middle of
the country, they
couldn't match with
Osteria Francescana,
because my mind was
already changed.
And I started thinking about
tradition, but in evolution.
I was looking at the
terroir in a different way.
A big wheel of Parmigiano
was no more a cheese to eat,
but was something
much more deep.
A drop of balsamic
vinegar was something
that I had to respect and
see in a different way,
maybe from under the table.
I don't know.
And like that, I started with
my wife this dialogue with art.
And art-- usually the eye is
the expression of a human being.
And it makes visible
the invisible.
So starting from there,
compressing all of these ideas,
we started creating
edible bites where
culture became our
motivational force.
So a few years later,
I had the opportunity
to meet Ferran Adria, this
Spanish chef who was creating,
in his restaurant, elBulli,
a revolution on technique.
And he invited me there, too.
And so I left
everything another time,
and I went to elBulli to learn.
And I was thinking to learn
all of these techniques
that they could
make me maybe create
a foam of Parmigiano-Reggiano.
I don't know.
And but actually what
Ferran was teaching
me was freedom-- freedom
to express yourself,
the freedom of thinking
and looking inside you,
and bring out all
these memories, ideas,
through technique but
creative gestures.
I came back from the
experience at elBulli
and all these gastronomic
critics in Italy--
can you imagine?
In Italy, you don't have to
touch three things-- the Pope,
the national soccer team,
and the grandmother recipes.
You can do whatever you want.
You can do whatever you want,
but not these three things.
So I was like, oh my god.
What am I going to do?
But these gastronomic
critics and the chefs,
they were playing jokes--
oh, what is he going to do?
Bottura, he's going to
make like mortadella foam.
That's a great idea.
That's a beautiful idea.
So I'm going to make
a mortadella foam.
Why?
In honor of my
mother-- that she was
the one who pushed me
to be and to follow
my passion through the kitchen.
And since I was 14, she was
bringing a bologna sandwich--
are you calling mortadella
bologna right here?
So bologna sandwich-- that's
bologna, from Bologna--
in a backpack, saying,
Massimo, [ITALIAN].
You have to eat.
You have to eat if
you want to grow.
Not just playing soccer.
And for that
reason, I just start
thinking about those kinds of
things that are icons for us.
But trying not to see
and to look at them
in a nostalgic way,
but in a critic way--
to bring the best from
the past into the future.
So one recipe from
another, I started
getting so
irreverent, so ironic.
So I was creating
all these plates that
would provocate people,
provocate the mind.
But just to attract
the point of view,
like Tortellini are
Walking on the Broth.
Serving six tortellini.
Can you imagine in Modena
serving six tortellini
in the middle of the broth?
They were like, what the
hell is he going to do?
Or what they think is--
Or Compression of
Pasta and Beans.
In Compression of
Pasta and Beans,
I was just thinking about
creating my gastronomic life,
compress my gastronomic
life into a small glass,
serving pasta and beans-- one
of the most classic recipes
of Italian gastronomy.
But in Compression
of Pasta and Beans,
I create this sortification
process in a small glass.
Where at the bottom, there
was like my experience
with French cuisine.
So and I was creating
this creme royale.
Do you know the French?
No?
Creme royale.
So they were adding a
little bit of foie gras.
It's like "Pulp Fiction", no?
Royale with cheese.
It's just a cheeseburger.
OK?
So pig skin, beans,
and foie gras.
And I created this creme
royale on the bottom.
Then some brunoise
of red radicchio,
so a little bit of bitterness.
Saute it with red
wine-- so acidity.
Then a creamy sauce of beans,
as a very traditional style.
And then ending with a foam
of very air of rosemary.
Because rosemary is very
intense and very aggressive.
So creating an air
of rosemary, you
have just a little
touch in the back part
of the palate of the
flavor of rosemary.
So the first homage
was for Ducasse,
and the last one was
for Ferran Adria--
my first and my last
gastronomic experience.
But in the middle,
instead of serving pasta,
I introduce Parmigiano-Reggiano
crust boiled into the beans.
As my grandmother would
say-- because that's
a secret that every
grandmother knows.
But I sliced across the
Parmigiano as they were pasta.
So this kind of
[ITALIAN] like bad cuts.
So between Ducasse and Ferran
Adria, I put my grandmother.
That's the idea of
the pasta and beans.
And after all these years
and all this experience,
we realized that
we were creating
a very interesting cuisine.
Because everyone was looking
at us, and especially
the Michelin Guide.
And we arrived, at
one point, in which
we started getting all
these awards and things.
But people, they
keep giving us space
in which we had like
this point, this critic
point of our creativity.
And at that point,
the dialogue with art
started getting
more deep and deep.
And we started
creating plates as they
were like, more emotional
than just traditional,
as we are explaining
in the book.
So we create plates that-- they
start dialogues with yourself,
with my mind, with the
approach with the people.
Like, Oops, I Dropped
the Lemon Tart.
Oops, I Dropped the Lemon Tart.
Or 1,000 Layers of Leaves.
It means in a word like this,
full of obsession, obsession
and obligation, in which
you have, every day,
I have to go here.
I have to go there.
I have to-- the lawyer and
the account and the bank.
I have to pay the bills.
You know, if you don't leave a
little space open for poetry,
this life is going to
disappear like this.
And if you see
that moment and you
realize that those moments are
the moments, the most important
moments in which you can jump
and feel the poetry inside you,
it's the moment in which you
are in the middle of a service.
You have your
pastry chef that is
ready to serve two lemon tart.
And these are Japanese
guys-- the most precise guys
in the world, and the
most incredible talented.
And he drops one of
the two lemon tarts.
And he's like, ready
to kill himself.
And he's like, what the hell?
What's going on?
I said Taka, it's the most
beautiful tart you can serve.
It's the imperfection.
Because you're so perfect
that you create something
imperfect that I love it.
And that's the moment in
which we jump into the poetry,
and we imagine and
we see the world
from another point of
view, from under the table.
And in that moment, we create
Oops, I Dropped the Lemon Tart.
It became an icon of the
international cuisine.
So what is the book?
The book is the compression
of 20 years of our work,
the compression of our passion--
the art, the music, the food.
It's storytelling.
Every recipe is a story. it's
more a book about creativity.
It's more a book about memory.
What is Italy in
a very deep way?
Look at foggy parts of Bologna
or the wind of Pantelleria
that is like giving this
feeling of salty capers
naturally in the
middle of the sea.
The magic flavor of an almond
of Noto, or like anchovies
water from the Gulf of Sorrento.
So it's about that.
It's about emotion.
And it's about the whole life
that I dedicate with my wife,
with my team-- that I never
forget about the team--
to create and to give to
everyone, to the young chef,
the opportunity to imagine
and to dream about the future.
Thank you very much.
You're going to
taste-- we brought
some balsamic vinegar
and some Parmigiano.
So it's like my
blood in the vein
and the cheese that made
my muscles like that.
So I'm not that skinny, right?
And so just to say,
this vinegar-- and I'm
very proud of-- just won the
gold medal in Spilamberto
as the best vinegar
in the world.
So it's very important
for us that everyone
thinks that we are so avant
garde, but it's not true.
We have the feet very
deep into tradition,
and we really care about that.
And this is the
expression of what
we are through Parmigianos,
balsamic vinegar.
To think about we grew
up as kids listening
to the sound of the pipes of
the Ferrari or the Maserati.
But at the end, in a dark
part of the house, where
the winter hits very heavy or
the summer is getting boiling,
[INAUDIBLE], there
is balsamic vinegar
that stayed there for
decades and became,
after years and years
and years, a liquid gold.
This is crazy, no?
For 2014, thinking about that
you create a product that
takes, like, 25 years
before it tastes?
But I just brought to share with
you with this kind of emotion.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank
you so much, Massimo.
We have time for 5, 10
minutes of questions,
if anyone has a
question they'd like
to ask while we're
doing the tasting.
AUDIENCE: If there
was one American chef
you could work for,
who would it be?
MASSIMO BOTTURA:
I could work for?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
MASSIMO BOTTURA: This is--
this is something that--
AUDIENCE: Who would
you stage with?
MASSIMO BOTTURA: I
never work for anyone.
I work for Ray [? Costantini ?]
in New York, when
it was 1993-- where
I met my wife, Lara.
And it was Cafe de [? Nona ?].
He was a Calabrian
guy, hairdresser.
And he was giving
party to his house.
And everyone would say, oh, Ray.
You're so good at cooking.
You just have to
open a restaurant.
It was like, when I met him,
he was sleeping in the basement
after the first
month of opening.
He didn't know
anything about food,
anything about the restaurant.
He was so tired that he was
like, sleeping in the basement.
I worked for him.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
[LAUGHTER]
And the second question is,
hypothetically it's 12:00 AM.
You've had a couple
glasses of wine.
What are you going
to cook for yourself?
MASSIMO BOTTURA: 12:00 AM?
A glass of wine?
What glass of wine?
AUDIENCE: Barolo.
Red.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK.
Barolo.
MASSIMO BOTTURA: What
I cook for myself.
Actually, a glass of Barolo
at midnight can be by itself.
You know?
No, because it's like-- you
know, Barolo is [INAUDIBLE].
You eat and you drink.
Because it's so
complex that when
you feel the Barolo,
you just, in the nose,
you have red fruit.
You have toasted almond.
You have the old earth--
also truffles sometimes.
And it's so complex
that, you know, choose
something at midnight like
that is a tricky question.
No.
I don't know.
Something-- maybe a culatello,
like a slice of culatello,
very old.
You chew the same feeling,
like a porcini mushroom,
black truffle.
AUDIENCE: What would
you eat for street food
if you were traveling?
MASSIMO BOTTURA: Street
food is I love street food.
Actually, in two days, I'm
going to cook street food too.
I'm going in New
York, and I create
a burger for Shake
Shack for Columbus Day.
And it's going to be
a burger in which I
mix some beef with cotechino.
Are you familiar with cotechino?
Cotechino is a sausage,
very traditional,
created 500 years ago in
Mirandola, a small village
outside of Modena.
And it's just pig ground
with also the skin
part, that you cook
and you defat it.
But it's very gelatinous,
and it's incredible
when there is no
fat, because you
feel the gelatin everywhere.
And so I ground this meat.
I cook it and I mix it with
the gelatin with the beef,
and some sum
Parmigiano-Reggiano.
So like 30% to 20% of
cotechino, 70% of meat,
and 10% of Parmigiano-Reggiano.
So it's the perfect umami
with the gelatin inside.
And salsa verde,
as Emilia-Romagna,
we serve close to the
meat with acidity,
the chlorophyll of the salad, so
imagine these kinds of things.
And the mayonnaise made with
balsamic vinegar for the fries.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's Michelin Star
quality street food.
MASSIMO BOTTURA: I hope so.
I hope so.
The point is that
everyone is tweeting that.
And every single website is
like talking, ah, Columbus Day--
everyone at Madison Park.
So can you imagine what's
going on in Madison Park?
Just last night I was sleeping,
and I wake up like that.
I see 3,000 people there
waiting for the burger.
What I'm supposed to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to talk about criticism.
And I know Italians are very
outspoken in their criticism.
And you kind of--
MASSIMO BOTTURA: Really?
I didn't know that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's new.
But you sort of went
away from tradition.
You almost shocked a culture.
How do you deal with the
criticism on a daily basis,
in the restaurant,
outside of the restaurant?
MASSIMO BOTTURA:
You know, yesterday,
in the most important
guide, l'Espresso guide,
from Italy-- it's like
37 years of history.
He came out for the
fifth time, sixth time,
like, best chef, best
restaurant in Italy.
And instead of
saying, ah, great!
It's beautiful What
a restaurant we have.
Is like, oh.
What boring.
It's always [INAUDIBLE].
It's like, you know--
what I'm supposed to say?
Say thank you, or
what do I have to do?
And it's like, still,
now, after everything,
there are people that are coming
in with the five different age
of Parmigiano-Reggiano
and five different texture
and temperature.
You know, an iconic
dish that you see
and that have the
recipe in the book.
And in the beginning, it
was creating 20 years ago.
And after it evolved in '98,
the aging process, and 2002,
and 2011, it has been
declared the plate
of the decade for
Italian gastronomy.
So it's like an
incredible honor.
Like two weeks ago, there was
a customer that was like, yeah,
it's good, but, you know, I
would put something like that,
and I would change this.
And I say, oh,
that's a good idea.
I'm going to take notes, and
I'm going to think about that.
What do you have to say?
It's normal.
In Italy, for me,
I'm used to it.
So there's no problem.
15 years ago, I risk
to get the burned
in the main piazza as a witch.
So.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We
can take two more.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I had a question on how
you made your vinegar so
fruitful and sour, on
that perfect blend?
MASSIMO BOTTURA:
It's just a question.
It's just a way of waiting.
Choose the right barrels.
Choose the right woods.
Make the perfect musto--
the must, the reduction
of the grape juice.
And then wait.
And then trust your palate.
Every single wood is
giving you something.
It's talking to you.
Like you have juniper,
and it's telling you
that you're going to have
incense, chocolate, coffee.
You have cherry wood.
You're going to have sour
cherry, fresh red fruit,
a little bit of plants.
You have oak.
It's telling you something.
So what I did-- I just followed
my ideas and my palate.
I moved different barrels.
And instead of having
the juniper as everyone
has at the end of
all these barrels,
I move the juniper in the middle
and the cherry at the end.
So I got this fresh and balanced
flavor that is just, to me,
is just perfect like that.
And, you know, I got the gold
medal, so they [INAUDIBLE].
It was a blind tasting, so
no one can say anything.
AUDIENCE: What do you
cook for your family?
MASSIMO BOTTURA: I never cook.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
We are very lucky that
we have the opportunity
to have incredible ingredients.
And another thing that my
wife-- she's from New York.
So she arrived in Modena,
and the first thing
she did-- she went
to my mom and learned
how to make ragu, how
to make passatelli.
So she's very good
at cooking, and she's
the one who cooks for the
children and for the family.
But also ingredients, you know?
When you have a
great ingredient,
like the perfect burrata,
or the mozzarella
that when you break it,
all the milk is coming out,
and it's amazing.
Or like ham, or these
sweet anchovies.
You know?
Put together everything and--
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Please
join me one more time
in thanking Massimo for
joining us here [INAUDIBLE].
MASSIMO BOTTURA: [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]